wenn es zur aktuellen kuh wohnanlage
lassen sie mich kurz vorher bevor wir
beginnen weil es immer wieder
missverständnisse darüber gibt wer die
bundespressekonferenz ist und was sie
macht zwei worte sagen die
bundespressekonferenz ist ein
zusammenschluss ein verein den
journalistinnen und journalisten
angehören die für vielfältigste medien
in deutschland über bundespolitik
berichten dem verein gehören neben
journalisten an die diese
pressekonferenzen organisieren und auch
leiten und so ermöglichen dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen hier ihre
fragen stellen können das gleiche gilt
für kolleginnen und kollegen des vereins
der auslandspresse
die für ausländische medien aus berlin
berichten heute geht es erneut um die
wohnanlage und ich begrüße dazu herzlich
neben mir bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach dann eben den präsidenten des
robert koch instituts professor lothar
wieler und da neben den
wissenschaftlichen leiter des die wie
intensiv registers professor christian
karagiannis herzlich willkommen im 3 wir
werden von allen dreien eingangs
statement schon bevor wir wie gewohnt zu
ihren fragen kommen und der minister
beginnt ja vielen lieben dank vor bushs
dass wir auch hier ihre gäste sein
dürfen ich möchte euch bedanken dass
kollege karagiannis heute mit dazu
gekommen ist und uns die situation auf
den intensivstationen aber nicht nur da
sein wird und auch vielen dank wähler
dass sie wieder dabei sind in bewährter
manier ich komme mal kurz zunächst auch
die situation zu sprechen wo sind wir
derzeit ich glaube wir haben jetzt hat
die
mikrowelle in deutschland gut in der
kontrolle das ist eine also welle für
die gilt dass man also die welle selbst
die pandemische welle nicht
kontrollieren kann man kann aber die
folgen kontrollieren und das ist unser
ziel wir wollen die folgen minimieren
das sehe was wir ausgegeben haben und
auch als bundesregierung auch in
abstimmung also mit bundeskanzler scholz
aber nicht nur ist dass wir durch diese
welle durch kommen wollen mit zum
wenigen schweren verläufen und
todesfällen wie möglich das ist das ziel
was wir uns gesetzt haben und dafür muss
es leicht werden dass möglichst viele
ältere menschen durch diese welle durch
kommen ohne dass sie schwer erkranken
wir haben in deutschland ein
sonderproblem wir haben eine sehr alte
bevölkerung die zweitälteste bevölkerung
in europa nach italien und wir haben
darüber hinaus eine sehr hohe zahl von
ungeimpften in dieser hohen altersgruppe
bei den über 60 jährigen wir haben dort
firma so viele ungeimpfte wie england
und dreimal so viele ungeimpfte wie
italien das heißt wir haben das
besondere sind die besondere situation
sehr viele ältere menschen und von
dieser besonders bedrohten gruppe sind
viele im vergleich zu anderen ländern
umkämpft daher müssen wir diese also
gruppe schützen das ist das ziel unserer
maßnahmen und das ist keine kleinigkeit
obwohl nikon leichter verläuft müssen
wir damit rechnen dass viele von diesem
ältere menschen wenn sie ungeimpft
erkranken so schwer erkranken dass sie
intensiv wichtig werden und auch
versterben das ist das problem also es
wird dann fehlen so gehen und daher muss
man jetzt eine zwischenbilanz abgeben
und die zwischenbilanz ist bisher
positiv wir haben ruhe instanzen das hat
nicht überrascht ich habe hier in dieser
runde schon vorgetragen wir rechnen mit
täglichen inzidenz und von bis zu
400.000 fällen wir glauben aber also
dass die inzidenz dann wieder runter
geht nur wir wollen eben erreichen dass
in dieser welle möglichst wenige ältere
menschen erkranken und dass es bisher
gelungen die inzidenz ist im
durchschnitt 1000 bei den jüngeren ist
die inzidenz zum teil
2000 aber bei dieser wohlhabenden group
auf die es uns besonders ankommt liegt
sie zwischen 200 und 300 und das ist
sozusagen unser erfolg weil ich lese oft
und höre oft die politik hätte die
kontrolle in dieser welle verloren das
ist nicht der fall mit den hohen
fallzahlen hatten wir gerechnet ich habe
sie hier vorgetragen sie sind sogar
etwas niedriger als das modell des
robert-koch-instituts vorher berechnet
hatte wir liegen unter diesen
vorhersagen aber es ist uns heute
gelungen die älteren bisher durch die
maßnahmen die wir haben 3g 2g 3g plus
die älteren gut zu schützen das werden
wir weiter machen und dafür werden wir
jetzt auch noch ein paar anpassungen
vornehmen wir fahren weiter die booster
kampagne die poster kampagne ist etwas
zurückgegangen auch das ist keine
überraschung denn also auch bei der
booster kampagne ist es so diejenigen
die besonders überzeugt sind melden sich
zuerst diejenigen die man schwer
überzeugen kann die werden sich danach
darüber hinaus omikron gilt als etwas
harmloser sind jetzt viele der meinung
fälschlicherweise dass die booster
impfung nicht notwendig wäre das spielt
uns nicht gerade in die karten
und dazu kommt viele haben mit sorge die
booster impfung die mit dem alten
impfstoff erfolg ist vielleicht nicht
optimal und bürger warten bis die
omnicom so impfungen kommen auch das ist
falsch ich gehe durch die drei punkte
ganz kurz durch die booster impfung
hilft derzeit den eltern unbedingt dort
ich rufe dort jeden auf die brust zu
nehmen zum zweiten die alte neben stoffe
die wir jetzt noch haben und moderne
aber auch bei und wir haben beides jetzt
in der in dem umfang zur verfügung wie
das brauchen schützen
drastig foto dass sich centers of
disease control haben jetzt noch einmal
ausgewertet dass das risiko zu sterben
durch die booster impfung im vergleich
zum ungeimpften status um 99 prozent
sind und zwar mit diesen alten stoffen
mit den impfstoffen die wir vor zwei
jahren entwickelt haben sinkt das risiko
zu sterben um 99% ich appelliere daher
von dieser stelle nochmal von diesem
sitzplatz drama weg bitte lassen sie
sich postern sie tun sich den größten
gefallen den sie sich tun können warten
sie nicht auf impfstoffe die noch in der
entwicklung sind nehmen sie dem stoff
für die da sind 99 prozent wird was also
risiko gesenkt wir werden in der
nächsten woche ikone schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung noch einmal anpassen
in bezug auf die isolations freie
testung bei den also medizinischen
kritisch bei diesem personal wir werden
eine neue tasche des strategie- und test
verordnung vorlegen eng abgestimmt mit
den ländern und wir werden darüber
hinaus auch regeln für die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung vorlegen
auch sehr eng abgestimmt mit den ländern
wir arbeiten an allen drei
regeln schon sehr intensiv mit den
ländern zusammen die letzten
besprechungen mit einer untergruppe der
länder hat es gestern nacht also
stattgefundenen 21 uhr stattgefunden
daran wird sehr intensiv gearbeitet ich
komme also zum ende meiner auswirkung
wir also kontrollieren die wellen unser
ziel ist uns durch diese welle durch
gekommen dass wir dann zurückblicken
kann und sagen in deutschland sind sehr
wenige ältere menschen in dieser
schweren omikron welle noch gestorben
weil wir sie gut schützen konnten das
möchte ich dass man darauf zurückblickt
und dann schaut das war ein erfolg
ganzer hohe fallzahlen gehabt aber
weniger sterbefälle und dass wir in den
nächsten
monaten es schaffen so schnell möglich
schneller desto besser einen rückfall
abzuwenden im herbst durch die
einführung der allgemeinen impfung nicht
so dass man am ende des jahres dann
schauen kann und sagt die omikron welle
das hat deutschland gut geschafft da
sind wir mit wenigen positionen
durchgekommen hatten wir in der
kontrolle und einen schweren rückfall
hat es im herbst nicht gegeben weil
diese im pflückt die ich eben
beschrieben habe diese zwölf prozent bei
den über 60-jährigen die schließt sich
nicht von allein die schließt sich nicht
durch appelle die schließt sich nicht
indem wir also auf die risiken hinweisen
sondern die diskussion ist so verfahren
dass wir diese lücke aus meiner sicht
nur schließen werden mit der einführung
einer allgemeinen pflicht und die muss
auch früh kommen weil wenn sie nicht
früh kommt wird sie im herbst die impf
abdeckung nicht erreicht haben die wir
benötigen um diesen erfolg zu
ermöglichen so sehe ich die derzeitige
situation
und ja ich würde es dabei schon belassen
wollen gibt das wort sogar cvb
schauspieler haben sie das wort tag
meine damen und herren die fallzahlen
steigen weiter massiv an aber
tatsächlich steigen sie bei weitem nicht
so heftig wie es unter omikron möglich
wäre und das liegt daran dass sich die
allermeisten menschen verantwortungsvoll
daran halten an die maßnahmen die sie
alle kennen und ihre kontakte reduzieren
damit können wir folgen extrem hohe
fallzahlen für krankenhäuser und auch
für die versorgung allgemein noch etwas
geringer gehalten werden und wir
gewinnen tatsächlich mit jedem tag zeit
an dem wie viele weitere menschen impfen
lassen können und auch eine auffrischung
impfung nehmen und dadurch wird die
anzahl der schweren krankheitsverläufe
reduziert das ist genau das wichtige und
richtige ziel
trotzdem muss man natürlich klar sagen
dass wir in der mikrowelle jetzt
sozusagen auf einen höhepunkt zu steuern
wie sieht also die aktuelle lage aus
allein in den letzten sieben tagen haben
sich in deutschland rund 890.000
menschen infiziert das ist also quasi
ein prozent der gesamten bevölkerung
dass sie nur einer woche jeder dritte
durchgeführte pcr test in der letzten
woche war positiv aber ich hatte ja
schon gesagt dass wir mit micon in eine
neue phase der pandemie eintreten und
das in dieser jetzigen phase pandemie
die summe der fallzahlen nicht mehr das
entscheidende ist wir müssen jetzt in
erster linie auf die krankheitslast
und die krankheit schwerer schauen denn
das ziel bleibt weiterhin schwere
verläufe zu verringern und die
arbeitsfähigkeit von kliniken aber
natürlich auch von anderen kritischen
infrastrukturen aufrecht zu halten
und schauen wir mal auf die relevanten
parameter die sieben tage
hospitalisierung incidents liegt
adjustiert schon bei rund 7,5
und sie steigt aktuell das heißt die
zahl der stationär
behandlungs dürftigen co wird 19
patienten ist hoch und die krankenhäuser
bekommen dass jetzt auch schon zu spüren
wenn wir zusätzlich auf die
hospitalisierung daten aus der syndrom
mission zu regenschauern die ich ihnen
vor zwei wochen vorstellte und die gibt
uns ja auskunft über die kogit 19
patienten die wegen einer schweren
atemwegsinfektion
hospitalisiert werden dann sehen wir
einen anstieg der hospitalisierten in
den jüngeren altersgruppen also
denjenigen altersgruppen die sich in den
letzten zwei wochen infiziert haben in
den kliniken macht sich momenten noch
positiv bemerkbar dass die älteren noch
nicht so stark von omikron geschehen
betroffen sind das sprach minister
lauterbach eben an und das müssen wir
auch weiter als ziel im auge haben und
das ist ja klar dass hier die quote der
geimpften und auffrischimpfungen bei den
jüngeren fiel bei den älteren viel höher
ist als bei den jugendlichen und jungen
erwachsenen aber sie ist eben noch nicht
ausreichend hoch genug
auf zwei dinge sollten wir in den
nächsten beiden wochen besonders achten
erstens selbst wenn der anteil der
infektion durch micon mit schweren
verläufen geringer ist als bei delta
müssen wir allein durch die schiere
menge an infizierten wieder mit mehr
krankenhauseinweisungen rechnen das
sehen wir ja jetzt schon zweitens werden
in den kommenden wochen immer mehr
ältere menschen betroffen seien und wie
infektion mit omikron bei ihnen
verlaufen das können wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht genau einschätzen
wir befinden uns in einer neuen phase
der pandemie von beginn an haben wir die
strategie der eindämmung des schutzes
und der abmilderung verfolgt und in der
jetzigen pandemie phase kann aufgrund
der extrem hohen fallzahlen eine
eindämmung nur noch auf die wichtigsten
bereiche konzentriert werden unsere
strategie hat sich nicht geändert aber
weil inzwischen viele personen geimpft
sind oder den natürlichen kontakt mit
dem virus durch eine infektion hatten
müssen wir mit blick auf die sehr hohen
fallzahlen nun noch stärker den fokus
auf den schutz insbesondere der
wohlhabenden gruppen richten denn das
ist entscheidend jetzt müssen die
risikogruppen wieder ganz intensiv
geschützt werden was sich aber immer
mehr abzeichnet und das ist die
entscheidende botschaft wer geimpft ist
am besten dreifach kämpft ist ist in der
regel sehr gut vor schweren verläufen
auch mit micon geschützt nach wie vor
gilt je mehr infektionen wir verhindern
je langsamer als ich saß kopf zwei
ausbreitet desto besser schützen wir die
wohl mehr abeln mitmenschen und auch die
kritischen infrastruktur das gilt auch
jetzt noch auch bei nikon auch bei den
massiven fallzahlen wir dürfen uns von
der mikrowelle nicht überwältigen lassen
oder um bei dem tanker bild zu bleiben
dass ich an dieser stelle schon mal
bemüht habe die see ist stürmisch ja
und die sicht ist schlecht aber wir
müssen jetzt wirklich einen kühlen kopf
bewahren den tanker weiter auf kurs
halten und gemeinsam durch diesen strom
fahren wir wissen genau wo wir hinwollen
wir trotzen auch dieser welle auch sie
wird vorbeigehen und bis dahin halten
wir bitte weiter unsere kontakte gering
vermeiden wir
menschenansammlungen
tragen wir maske und zwar eng anliegen
über mund und nase
und lösten sie und regelmäßig wenn wir
mit mehreren menschen zusammen in einem
innenraum sind
und noch mal mein wirklich dringende
appell wenn sie es noch nicht getan
haben lassen sie sich bitte denken sie
auch an die auffrischimpfung je mehr
menschen immun sind umso schneller kann
diese pandemie beendet werden und die
impfung ist nun mal der sicherste weg
zur immunität
hätte
ja vielen dank guten morgen zusammen ich
möchte ihnen einen überblick geben über
die aktuelle lage um mich auch ein
bisschen der frage widmen was zum
patientenkollektiv haben wir jetzt zu
erwarten mit micon weil die frage extrem
häufig an mich herangetragen wird
vielleicht zu erstmals aktuellen lage
wir haben noch mehr als 2.000 patienten
auf den intensivstationen liegen
das ist noch eine deutliche belastung
auch wenn sich in einem akzeptablen
rahmen bewegt und weit weg ist von
dieser spitzenbelastung die wir mit den
5000 patienten jetzt zuletzt in der
del-tabelle hatten wir sehen sehr schön
den abfall der delta patienten auf der
intensivstation das ist auch eine gute
nachricht sicherlich das schlimmste
virus ist dass wir so gesehen haben in
der lungenheilkunde und auf den
intensivstationen den letzten 20 jahren
mit unglaublich vielen schweren und zehn
verläufen was wir aber auch sehen ist
dass wir so seit ungefähr sieben bis
zehn tagen eine seitwärtsbewegung bei
den neuaufnahmen haben hin zu einem
trend dass es jetzt vielleicht hoch geht
und das ist ziemlich eindeutig der
omicron effekte jetzt auch den
intensivstationen ankommt das ist alles
akzeptabel
aber es liegt natürlich daran dass wir
jetzt auch vermehrt diese hohen
incidents neben krankenhaus sehen
auf den normalen stationen stets die
situation etwas anders da als auf den
intensivstationen und wenn wir das
beispiel nordrhein-westfalen nehmen da
haben wir eine sehr gute und eine
übersicht über die kogit patienten jeden
tag und wir haben den stärksten anstieg
der kurve patienten im krankenhaus seit
beginn der pandemie und sind heute schon
wieder auf der spitze der del tabelle
mit knapp dreieinhalb tausend patienten
und das ist sehr deutlich und das wird
noch deutlicher werden mit den hohen
instituts und das führt uns natürlich
auf jeden fall ganz klar auch zu der
frage was sehen wir dort für patienten
ich will immer wieder die frage gestellt
kommen die mit oder wegen corona ich
darf sie vielleicht bitten die frage
umzuformulieren weil wenn sie einen
patienten vor sich haben gerade auf der
intensivstation er kann den luftkrieg
und sie fragen dem sind sie jetzt hier
mit oder wegen krone dann springt er ihn
geradeaus ins gesicht
ich glaube dass bessere learning ist
dass wir davon sprechen welche
krankheitslast haben wir mit der nikon
variante was ist die hauptdiagnose die
den patienten ins krankenhaus führt das
ist ganz wichtig und wie viele von denen
haben auch wirklich ein respiratorische
probleme also wie viele von denen haben
die pneumologie und ich glaube schon
dass wir auch im jetzigen system
möglichkeiten haben das zu überwachen
und lothar wieler hat sie eben
angesprochen wir haben diese komische
überwachung des lkws das heißt wir
wissen wie viele atemwegserkrankungen
wir haben intensiv register aber auch
die möglichkeit zumindest sogar
parameter dafür zu finden was auf den
intensivstationen passiert und sie
wissen alle dass der anteil der
beatmeten patienten extrem hoch ist bei
korrekt und der die ich zum teil bis zu
90 prozent mit der respiratorischen
unterstützung das war so die spitze der
del tabelle und haben einen kleinen
anteil der wird bei uns als danone
respiratorische unterstützung geführt
der nackt auf der spitze der delta werde
bei 10 prozent und wenn sie jetzt
zunehmend patienten haben die aufgrund
anderer gründe im krankenhaus landen
oder auf der intensivstation dann steigt
dieser anteil natürlich und was wir
stand heute sehen ist dass der anteil
jetzt bei ungefähr 20 prozent liegt und
das reflektiert auch ein bisschen dass
sie mehr andere patienten haben die das
virus mitbringen aber wir sollten nicht
vergessen dass co wird keine reine
lungenerkrankungen ist sondern ein
system erkrankungen die insbesondere
auch die gefäße bedrückt das wird mir
immer ein bisschen zu sehr vergessen
weil gerade diese entzündungsreaktion
den däninnen schichten der gefäße jedes
organ mit einbeziehen kann und ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt sehr genau den
nächsten wochen gucken wie sich dieser
anteil dieser fälle entwickelt die keine
unterstützung brauchen wie gesagt von 10
auf 20 prozent ist im moment und ich
erwarte dass wir in den nächsten wochen
vielleicht noch stärker werden das heißt
wir haben auch stand jetzt schon eine
überwachung dessen was wir für einen
patientenkollektiv auf den
intensivstationen haben nichtsdestotrotz
und ich glaube das ist mir besonders
wichtig für den kommenden winter auf den
müssen wir uns wirklich gut vorbereiten
ich habe mehr angst vor dem kommenden
winter als vor diesem und das führt uns
auch da hin dass wir uns jetzt glaube
ich so vorbereiten müssen dass wir
patienten individuelle daten ausleiten
und ich bin guter dinge dass wir das mit
karl lauterbach und lothar wieder
schaffen werden im laufe dieses jahres
systeme zu etablieren dass wir im
nächsten winter gut sagen können welcher
patient nicht auf den intensiv und
normalstation
ein punkt der mir noch wichtig ist die
kritische infrastruktur und wir haben in
unserer ersten stellungnahme des
expertenrates schon darauf hingewiesen
dass die kritische infrastruktur unter
stress geraten wird und wenn wir heute
200.000 infektionen haben und nächste
woche vielleicht 400.000 dann ist das
ein echter stresstest für die kritische
infrastrukturen im land ich bin sehr
dankbar dass viele unsere anregung
aufgegriffen haben und dienstpläne noch
mal überarbeitet haben und sich gut
darauf vorbereitet haben aber ich glaube
die nächsten wochen werden nicht nur in
den krankenhäusern hart werden weil viel
personal ausfällt und auch viele kinder
einfach zu hause betreut werden müssen
von eltern die in der kritischen
infrastruktur arbeiten selbst wenn sie
selbst nicht infiziert sind und zum
abschluss soll mir noch mal ein
persönliches wort gestattet an die
mitarbeiterinnen im gesundheitswesen wir
haben jetzt zwei jahre panini hinter uns
und
wir haben im ambulanten und stationären
sektor unglaublich viele patienten
behandelt das sind jetzt knapp 600.000
krankenhauspatienten in zwei jahren
davon
150.000 auf den intensivstationen
der größte teil davon war beatmen die
hälfte der waadt mit dem patienten ist
verstorben wäre extrem viel leid gesehen
in den letzten beiden jahren und ich
glaube davor kann man nur den hut ziehen
um sich nur tief verneigen vor dieser
leistung die die mitarbeiterinnen im
gesundheitswesen erbracht haben und ich
glaube es gebührt auch den respekt vor
dieser leistung dass wir das schiff
jetzt für die nächsten wochen auf kurs
halten und ich glaube da ist wirklich
viel licht am ende des tunnels aber ich
glaube den kurs den brauchen wir jetzt
noch von gewissen zeitraum und damit
dadurch nicht bedanken
danke dafür dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen an dieser stelle nochmal die
erinnerung beziehungsweise die
dringliche bitte sich auf eine frage zu
beschränken ja viele fragen hier im saal
notiert und auch online damit einfach
wegen der begrenzten zeit möglichst
viele kollegen die möglichkeit kriege
eine frage zu stellen das gilt natürlich
auch für die online eingereichten fragen
ich werde dann im zweifel einfach nur
die erste nehmen und ich beginne mit
fragen die online gestellt wurden co2
zusammen weil es bei beiden um das thema
was ändert sich bei den tests geht julia
frisch von der ärzte zeitung fragt wann
ist mit der neuen test verordnung
bezüglich der priorisierung der pcr test
zu rechnen und werden wegen der
priorisierung andere personengruppen gar
keinen anspruch mehr auf einen pcr-test
haben und christina hofmann ähnliche
frage was wird sich beim testen und der
kontakt nach folgen konkret ändern
ich denke die fragen gehen an mich
vielen dank wir werden in der nächsten
woche eine entsprechende
test verordnung vorliegen wir sind in
der abstimmung mit den ländern nicht der
schon erwähnt dass gestern abend 21 uhr
noch eine runde mit einigen ländern
gedreht wurde werden am wochenende
weiter arbeiten das ist als bedürftig
und in der nächsten woche werden wir
also ein vorschlag mit den ländern
gemeinsam unterbreiten und
priorisierung sagt ist ja schon das
bedeutet nicht dass diejenigen die nicht
die priorität haben gar keinen anspruch
haben aber ihr anspruch ist sekundär und
es ist ja klar die details sind noch
vorzubehalten aber es ist ganz klar dass
hier zwei gruppen in der priorisierung
besondere bedeutung haben es ist zum
einen die gruppe derer die also in den
bereichen pflege
altenpflege krankenpflege aber auch in
der eingliederungshilfe tätig sind weil
dort muss der pcr test dazu führen dass
man eine mögliche infektion mehr so
schnell feststellt dass man die
schutzbefohlenen dass man die noch
schützen kann das muss gesichert sein
dass wir da nicht wie vor einem jahr
also in todesfälle haben die wir nicht
wollen dass mit schwerpunkt zahlen wir
wollen das einfach gar nicht wir wollen
dass in diesen bereichen tatsächlich die
pcr test um absolute priorität hat und
da gibt es natürlich auch eine andere
gruppe die besonders wollen habe liszt
zum beispiel menschen mit schweren
erkrankungen die also an erkrankungen
also mit nikon nur überstehen könnten
wenn man sie also früh behandelt und zu
dieser frühen behandlung gehört auch die
medikamentöse verbannung die antikörper
behandlungen also die behandlung mit
paco wird was wer rechtzeitig beschaffen
konnten wo wir jetzt also mit der
lieferung rechnen aber wir haben auch
noch andere medikamente und so rettet
man leben wenn jemand da sehr früh durch
den pcr test diagnostiziert wird und die
behandlung beginnt noch zu dem zeitpunkt
wo entweder antivirale komponente wird
oder das immunsystem unterstützt werden
schützen sie also den menschen
dahingehend dass er dann überlegt was er
sonst nicht was sonst nicht passiert
wäre und das sind für uns auf jeden fall
ich wähle der aso verordnung nicht
vorgreifen wir arbeiten intensiv daran
aber das sind auf jeden fall zwei
gruppen die dort auch die dort auf jeden
fall genannt sein werden und wie gesagt
wenn dann noch tests pcr-test lassen sie
mich ein punkt noch sagen es wird
sicherlich auch noch fragt werden das
grafisch stand vorab aus wieso machen
wir das nicht in wien gepolte testen
also das sind zwei dinge zu sagen zum
einen also geburt es hätten dazu geführt
dass wir jetzt eine höhere kapazität
hätte aber so etwas muss man vorberaten
und zwar bevorzugt zu dem zeitpunkt wo
es nicht viele fälle gibt denn wenn sie
die labors umstellen wollen auf ein
solches verfahren machen sie das am
besten wenn nicht gerade so eine große
belastung ist jetzt wäre das vollkommen
unmöglich wie das dauert seine zeit ich
hatte das selbst im mai 2020 für den
sommer dann den sommer 20 vorgeschlagen
ich hatte es auch noch mal vorgeschlagen
für den sommer 21 dass es damals nicht
gemacht worden wir haben uns schon eine
andere strategie in deutschland
entschieden die anti gen test strategie
das ist aber auch eine gute test
strategie man darf jetzt nicht alles
schlecht reden der anti gen test ist für
die also nicht priorisierten bereiche
ist das sehr hilfreich weil da wird zwar
am anfang der infektion
fälle übersehen
aber das sind dann die fälle die also
auch noch nicht so stark also infektiös
sind das andere angesteckt werden können
und somit wenn man die anti gen test
klug ansetzt dann kann man auch mit
dieser strategie die mikrowelle sehr gut
beherrschen und das war ja die strategie
für die wir uns hier entschieden hatten
die für die sich auf meine vorgänger
entschieden hatten das ist jetzt auch
nicht zu kritisieren aber wir dürfen
nicht den fehler machen dass wir sagen
jetzt haben wir nur die anti gen test
wir haben keine kontrolle sondern wenn
man den die antigen testflug einsetzt
dann kann man die welle damit gut
beherrschen insbesondere beim freie
testen wo der antigen test sehr sicher
ist und der antigen das ist auch sehr
spezifisch wenn er jetzt positiv ist war
bei der hohen prävalenz das wort kollege
wieder bestätigen wollen gehört die
prävalenz sind desto größer ist der wert
eines positiven also an die gegend ist
der sogenannte positiver voraussage wert
ist dann höher und damit ist also in der
jetzigen situation der antigen test
schon gut unterwegs und also jetzt
darüber zu lamentieren was wäre gewesen
werden wir ein pooling angeführt hatte
das führt uns in der krise nicht weiter
der charakter des sie wollten es ja ich
würde gerne noch einen punkt ergänzen in
der gesundheitsminister gerade aufgebaut
hat das sind die neuen therapieformen
und
wir haben seit dieser woche in
deutschland ja nicht nur die aktive
immunisierung mit mit den impfstoffen
sondern wir haben auch eine passive
immunisierung und wir haben seit dieser
woche jetzt auch gegen die omikron
variante das medikament soto bima zur
verfügung das flächendeckende
ausgeliefert worden ist wir sind aus
medizinischer sicht da wirklich dankbar
und ich halte es für bemerkenswert weil
es in amerika ausverkauft ist und
eigentlich schon nicht mehr zu bekommen
ist und wir haben es jetzt in
deutschland die wir das
gesundheitsministerium und auch zur
verfügung und ist ist vor allen dingen
gut für ungeimpfte risikopatienten oder
für risikopatienten die mutmaßlich keine
ansprechen auf die impfungen haben ja
wir sind gut aufgestellt in deutschland
man kann verabreichen es wird über die
vene gegeben wir haben viele zentren in
deutschland und ich glaube deswegen ist
wichtig dass die wir dieses angebot in
den nächsten wochen noch nutzen danke
dann wären wir fahren weiter
am kader macht in deutschland ist ein
bisschen der der eindruck eines relativ
widersprüchlichen einer wieder spielen
kommunikation zum einen haben wir diese
rekorde infektions erwidert noch mal
gesagt das ist nicht mehr
ausschlaggebend trotzdem ist die
wahrnehmung dass diese wand sich gerade
auf der anderen seite werden maßnahmen
gelockert zuletzt in bayern wieder bis
zu 10.000 menschen in den stadien
es gibt den einen teil der bevölkerung
der jetzt wieder rausgeht den anderen
der sich auch angst zurückzieht am was
gedenken sie zu tun lautet warum dieser
wahrnehmung hall widersprüchlichen
kommunikation eines chaos
entgegenzuwirken wieder mehr klarheit
bringen
da 94 die frage also dass die beste
strategie bei so etwas ist als auch dass
man also bei der wahl bleibt also wir
haben in deutschland relativ strenge
regeln wir haben zwei g plus in den also
in den ressorts in den cafés die also
klubs die diskothek und sind komplett zu
wir haben nach wie vor fast
flächendeckend also zweig in den
geschäften wir haben also relativ
strenge regeln am arbeitsplatz aber auch
im öpnv wir machen eine relativ also
offensiver booster kampagne somit wenn
man jetzt die länder um uns herum mit
uns objektiv vergleich also wenn man
sich die mühe macht und macht an der so
genannte liste was geht hier was wir den
anderen bleibt also man also sagen wir
wenn man sich dem thema mit zahlen
objektiv löst dann lösen sich die
widersprüche ja auch denn dann sieht man
dass wir an relativ konservativen kurs
fahren der würde dann erwarten lassen
dass wir bei den älteren weniger hohe
fallzahlen haben und genau passieren
hier kollege wie landesebene noch einmal
betont somit das objektive ist relativ
eindeutig wenn jetzt also beispielsweise
ein gericht und wie gesagt keine gericht
stellte hier eine regel kassiert oder
ein land also
sich profiliert in dem dem das land sagt
wir haben die größte garage europas und
wir können daher also
fußballspieler zu lassen bei uns muss
keiner mit dem zug oder mit dem bus
anreisen die aero solar bleiben also
alle verteilt die menschen können in
diese riesen garage reinfahren die
größte garage europas so dass also
niemals die sich gegenseitig dann muss
ich damit leben aber ich muss immer
wieder das objektiv in den vordergrund
stellen also ich muss immer mit dem
objekt für mich ist das objektive das
wichtige sind wir wirklich richtig
unterwegs
schaffen wir das schaffen wir
tatsächlich die fallzahlen bei den
älteren mädels lassen die intensiv fälle
steigen jetzt im moment sich tagen aber
nicht so steil da sind wir auf dem weg
den wir hier durch das lka modell
vorgegeben haben oder sind es nicht von
daher halte ich bin da bin ich auch
immer noch offen gesagt nicht nur der
minister sondern der wissenschaftler
nicht einfach wo ich stehen wir jetzt
gemessen an den zahlen
wie sie richtig verstehe die signale der
lockerung jetzt eben ausländern in
bayern kommen oder auch aus
nachbarstaaten wie wieder eine malstraße
allerdings wenig halten sie für falsch
in dieser schweren situation
ich glaube bei einem kurs den ich also
hier schon so häufig vorgetragen habe
auch heute wieder ich begrüße die
lockerungen nicht ich denke dass wir
hier also den zenit der schweren fälle
noch nicht überschritten habe nicht im
paradies zu den ich seit langer zeit
kenne ich hätte zu seiner einschätzung
tomaten auch gebeten heute hier zu
entscheiden ich hätte zu seiner
einschätzung genau so ein dass wir vor
dem zenit der welle noch stehen also das
ziel ist dass wir möglichst wenige
todesfälle haben und möglichst wenige
fälle wie longo wird ich möchte auch
dass wenig möglich dass möglichst wenige
fälle diese also gefäß komplikationen
bekommen die mit einer krone infektionen
einhergehen und dass ich möchte auch
dass möglichst wenige menschen also
diese einmal verschlechterungen ihrer
sammlung durchblutung im gehirn bekommen
die bei einem schweren verlauf
beobachtet wird all das ist was für mich
im vordergrund steht und wenn das in
dänemark anders gemacht hat dann ist das
dänemark aber dass sind nicht wir wir
sehen das nicht
tobias schmid von der neuen osnabrücker
zeitung fragt frage richtet sich auch an
den minister kinderärzte warnen dass
quarantäne und geschlossene kita gruppen
für kinder viel schädlicher sein als
crooner schreibt er macht es ihnen sorge
dass trotzdem wieder massenhaft schul
und kita kinder nach hause geschickt
werden und in berlin die präsenzpflicht
ausgesetzt worden ist ich finde es
schwierig wenn man so etwas
gegeneinander rechnet also wenn man sagt
also der präsenzunterricht also fällt
aus die kinder nehmen schwere schäden
ich glaube also hat auch als betroffener
also vater dass es sehr davon abhängt
also wie das ganze organisiert ist ob s
hybrid unterricht ist ob die kinder sich
also ob die kinder mitgenommen werden
und so weiter natürlich wäre es mir
lieber wenn wir die welle schon hinter
uns hätten und dass die ich im
vordergrund das was wir hier gerade
besprochen haben dass wir die bälle
flach halten und also kontrollieren
führt auch dazu dass wir möglichst
schnell wo ich die welle durch kommen
das ist das was wir für die kinder tun
können ich muss das anders ausdrücken
meine position ist die funktion ist die
schulpolitik ist ja weitestgehend
landespolitik wir helfen da indem wir
zum beispiel informationen geben wir
gehen zum beispiel informationen bei wie
viel prozent also gibt es zum beispiel
auch longo fit bei kindern bei wie viel
prozent kommt das was wären symptome das
sind fragen wo wir helfen bei der
eigentlichen also regelungen wie der
unterricht stattzufinden hat das sind
die länder ja autonom aber was wir tun
wir begrenzen die welle in der gänze
denn die besser wie die welle in der
gänze begrenzen er ist ein schneller und
besser kommen wir auch für die kinder
durch
wir machen weiter hier im saal mit der
nächsten tage
könnten sie bitte damit sie alle
verstehen ans mikro michael haselrieder
zl frontal eine frage noch zu den
schulen der lauterbach da gibt es sehr
viele infektionen viele eltern sagen und
mikron raus da gerade durch ist es nicht
zumindest für die bereiche so dass da
die politik die kontrolle verloren bzw
aufgegeben hat weil da wird ja auch
nicht mehr ich vernünftig getestet jetzt
na ja zunächst wird an vielen stellen
noch getestet und also was die schulen
angeht ist die antigen testung also nach
wie vor eine gute testo übrigens wenn es
wenn es anders wäre dann müssten sie
auch gar nicht wie viele fälle es
überhaupt gibt wir haben gar keine
kontrolle verloren das ist es nur das
problem ist nicht dass die kontrolle
verloren haben das problem ist dass die
fallzahlen so sind das ist das
eigentliche problem und ich habe ja auch
hier schon oft vorgetragen dass es also
studien gibt die zeigt was einen
unterschied machen würde also dass wir
eben dass die kinder konsequent meisten
tragen dass also nach jeder
unterrichtsstunde gelüftet wird dass man
darüber hinaus die kinder die also
positiv sind dass man sie sofort also
isoliert und da ist uns der antiken test
sehr gut weil ich das ergebnis sofort
habe er also pcr test kommt oft als
ergebnis später rein
und dann kann das kind schon andere
kinder infiziert haben somit haben wir
also wenn das so wäre würde man zum
beispiel erwarten dass die bundesländer
also die geburten pcr tests in den
schulen machen dass die nicht wesentlich
besser dastehen als länder die mit dem
antigen testarbeiten das wäre dann die
hypothese mit dem man dann arbeiten
würde genau das sieht man von daher die
kontrolle haben wir nicht verloren ist
es aber einfach schade dass wir diese
hohe fahrzeuges haben aber schauen sie
in andere länder england beispielsweise
genauso war es da auch da waren zum teil
die instanzen wesentlich höher wir
müssen die gesamtwerte beschränken
bevor ich gleich zur nächsten frage
online komme ich bin nicht sicher ob
alle die sich bislang gemeldet haben mit
ihrer frage noch drankommen aber auch
online den hinweis dass fragen die jetzt
noch eingereicht werden mit ziemlicher
sicherheit nicht mehr rankommen eine
frage online gestellt von tim cent
ivanyi er vom redaktions netzwerk
deutschland zur einrichtung bezogenen
impfpflicht wiederum an den minister
haben die gesundheitsämter einen
ermessensspielraum beim umgang mit
impfwilligen pflegekräften und wenn
davon hängt er ab
also wer das ist ja bekannt dass ich was
die also
was ich was die also im aussetzung der
einrichtungs bezogenen höflich angeht
dass ich also keinen
verhandlungsspielraum sehe das gesetz
gilt und ist umzusetzen und wir müssen
tatsächlich die hat es ja auch eben
schon ausgeführt diese besonderes
vorhaben menschen müssen wir schützen
von daher ist die impfpflicht dort
gesetz recht und kann nicht ausgesetzt
werden und dazu fehlt übrigens auch jede
also dass dazu fehlt noch jede
gesetzgeberischer grundlage
beispielsweise für also die also für die
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste in
einzelnen bereichen eine ganz andere
frage ist aber die also wie wird die
umsetzung also gestaltet also was sind
zum beispiel sanktionen also wie
sichert man ab dass es nicht zu also
personalausfällen kommt welche also
personengruppen sind besonders hier also
in den vordergrund zu stellen und da
arbeiten wir natürlich den ländern nicht
nur zu sondern mit den sendern zusammen
weil es richtig wäre wenn es hier eine
einheitliche umsetzung gebe und da haben
die gespräche auch schon begonnen das
hat aber nichts mit der anderen frage zu
tun also wird das ausgesetzt somit die
schnelle antwort ist also aussetzen der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht so
wird nicht erhoben
dadurch natürlich spreche ich auch im
ausdrücklichen also einvernehmen mit
bundeskanzler chance das ganz genauso
sieht aber eine andere frage ist wie wir
das umgesetzt und wie über das
kontrolliert und da helfen wir natürlich
den ländern sowie können so wie wir
können
dann machen wir im saal
qualität zeitung herr lauterbach finden
sieht im bestrafung gefühl verbreitung
der herstellung von unrichtigen mv
ausweisen genug also vorgestern gab es
gerichtsurteil vom amtsgericht landstuhl
dort war drei monate zur bewährung
ausgesetzt und der zu ehren
informationen zwei drittel der
gerichtsverfahren werden ausgestellt im
allgemein und ein drittel bleibt und
danach kommt die bewehrung das liegt
daran dass alles lief und gemäß § 275
das gesetzbuch aber werde das unter
paragraf 267 richtige
und den urkunden fälschung dann konnte
die staffel
stellte also nicht so milde strafe
vielen dank
zunächst also ich betreibe keine
bewertung und auch kann er kritik der
gerichte die us gerichte also
präsentiere urteil das eine mal gefällt
mir ein urteil gefällt es mir nicht aber
ich möchte als minister hier nicht
eintreten in einem gerichts bewertung
und somit ist das so muss ich zum ersten
teil jetzt zum ersten teil ihrer frage
muss ich schweigen
das aber hat der für mich bedeutet haben
sich also für mich sind medizinisch und
auch also politisch aus diesen beiden
dimensionen sind für mich also
fälschungsdelikte bei info ausweisung
war genießen und ausweisen kein
kavaliersdelikt
das kann darauf hinauslaufen dass jemand
also sich ein solches dokument
erschleicht zutritt in eine
veranstaltung findet wo man sich darauf
verlassen muss das jeder geimpft ist
oder genesen ist nicht entsprechend
ansteckend ist und steckt an andere
wiederum an die möglicherweise mit dem
leben dafür bezahlen das ist nicht
akzeptabel in keiner art und weise daher
arbeiten wir auch beim thema also test
verordnung was ich eben schon
angesprochen hatte wir müssen jetzt eine
text verordnung kommen wo wir also eine
priorisierung vor im leben schon
vorgetragen was sind denn da
möglicherweise gruppen der arbeiten wir
an einer lösung die wir möglichst also
fälschungssicher
ausgestalten wollen somit das
problembewusstsein
für das problem was sie gerade
beschrieben haben ist da aber die lösung
ist nicht einfach und die also vieles
also was sagen wir jetzt bei
test nachweisen schwierig ist ist auch
der tatsache geschuldet dass die
damalige impfung vorgenommen werden
konnte zum beispiel auch in praxen ohne
das präzise dokumentiert werden konnte
oder musste wer ist überhaupt gegeben
worden so dass ich eine rückverfolgung
hier sehr schwer noch gewährleisten kann
aber wie gesagt die probleme sind
bekannt daran wird gearbeitet
und es wird nicht gering geschätzt wenn
es aber dann würde ich wirklich mitten
einer kurzen acht jahre stand wir haben
einander vorbei geredet ich habe nie
gesagt dass sie sollten die urteile
bewerten den schuldig entschuldigen sie
eine diskussion eine diskussion glaube
ich kann mir jetzt nicht führen weil
andere kollegen mit kollegen auch noch
ungeduldig darauf warten ihre frage
stellen zu können aber
auch das sollte von § § und das ist
arbeit der politiker nicht in der
richter
wir machen weiterhin der frageliste und
die nächste wäre jetzt tatsächlich auch
frau
herr lauterbach ich wollte mal fragen
welchen eindruck dann ist ihrer
einschätzung nach die debatte der
letzten tage auch die bundestagsdebatte
weil leute
überlegen
ich fand die debatte inhaltlich
hochwertig und es war eine völlig freie
debatte sie waren nicht polemisch oder
so sie war also
offen und war daher die genaue debatte
die wir führen müssen ich glaube nicht
dass diese debatte also jetzt großen
einfluss auf die frage hat also lasse
ich mich impfen oder nicht denn es war
ja also selbst bei denjenigen die die
impfpflicht
ablehnen immer wieder zu hören dass sie
sich selbst haben impfen lassen und auch
den wert der impfung nicht also in frage
stellen ich will nur ein einziges
beispiel bringen herr kubicki ich war
mit dem inhalt seiner rede war ich nicht
einverstanden das kann hier niemanden
der uns zugeschaltete so werden saales
überraschen aber auch herr kubicki hat
also darauf hingewiesen dass er geimpft
ist dass ihr dafür dankbar ist dass er
sich im kontakt impfen lassen konnte und
dass sie sich gestellt und das war
glaube ich der gemeinsame nenner den
diese debatte geatmet hat und daher
glaube ich ist durch die debatte also
sagen wir sind wir in der ethik
dimension weitergekommen aber der frage
wer lässt sich impfen oder nicht ist
also da ist kein schaden entstanden
eine frage von daniel pontzen vom zdf
die sich entweder an den minister oder
an herrn will errichtet er greift noch
mal das auf was professor karagiannis
gesagt hatte er wies darauf hin dass die
unterscheidung ob jemand mit oder wegen
alkohol ans krankenhaus komme auf der
intensivstation für den patienten
zweifel unerheblich sei und er fragt
jetzt wie definieren sie dann den
begriff hospitalisierung since it ends
werden darin patienten gezählt die mit
oder wegen bewohner ins krankenhaus
kommen
ja ich frage euch mal an und die also
die unterscheidung wird jetzt also im
präzisen nicht getroffen aus den gründen
die karagiannis vorgetragen hatte ich
wie das an einem beispiel
dann
wenn ein mensch also in die welt der
mann in die klinik kommt mit einer
herzschwäche dann führt das sehr oft
dazu dass sich wasser in der lunge steht
das ist ein ganz häufiger an klassikern
eine gefährliche situation ganz
gefährliche situation und wenn du dann
gleichzeitig an profit infiziert ist bis
seine prognose deutlich schlechter
sowieso lager muss man sagen die jetzt
schlechten wird kommt in vier stadien
wenn er mit dem vierten stadion new york
heart association viererreihen kommt
wird er karagiannis bestätigen das ist
keine kleinigkeit man muss man sofort
ran sondern patient ist schwer so einen
patienten kriegen ja heute noch schwer
durch ist keine kleinigkeit und wenn der
dann profitiert er kommt dann mit profis
nicht wegen kopiert ist die
wahrscheinlich sagen dass er verstärkt
sehr hoch von daher bestätige ich weiß
ja karagiannis eloquent vorgetragen hat
das spielen der praxis oft ghana oder
ich konnte beispiele bringen ohne ende
wenn zum beispiel ein hodgkin patienten
kommt eine art aus dem quoten krebs die
also in unterschiedlichen stadien kommen
wenn so ein patient mit profit reinkommt
dann ist es einfach sehr viel schlechter
müssen wir kämpfen und das sind also die
leute an die wir denken wenn ich die
jetzt alle aus der statistik heraus
nehme ich würde nur die reihen nehmen
die wege im cockpit kommen die anderen
aber nicht rein das wäre medizinisch
absolut unvertretbar also wer einfach es
ist einfach schlicht unsinn das wurde
einfach schlicht keinen sinn machen wenn
ich ehrlich sagen soll ich glaube
vielleicht wollen sie an der wähler oder
karagiannis dazu außen weil das ist eine
so wichtige frage da würde ich mich
freuen wenn sie unterstützen könnten
also das ist ja nicht das keine
kleinigkeit
ja ich will lothar wenn ich da
vielleicht wenn man dazu stellung
beziehen ich glaube sie dürfen auch
nicht vergessen dass jeder patient erst
mal die situation richtig ist ja es
völlig unabhängig davon was sie unter
erkrankungen ist und ich glaube das
extrembeispiel sind vielleicht
schwangere die zur entbindung kommen und
jetzt keinen schweren verlauf erleiden
werden aber trotzdem im fondsmanagement
her einfach kompliziert sind weil sie
einfach das virus mit sich tragen und
isoliert werden müssen und das wird uns
in den nächsten wochen wenn wir 400.000
infektionen haben pro tag vor ganz
schöne herausforderung stellen weil die
situations bereiche räumlich begrenzt
sind und da müssen wir uns etwas
einfallen lassen das ist in
krankenhäusern gut klappt ich glaube ich
würde das eher positiv jetzt mal da
rausnehmen und sagen ich habe ja viele
auf der digitalisierung herumgeritten
und ich glaube das ist auch wirklich
angekommen und dafür bin ich auch
dankbar aber ich glaube wir sollten das
jetzt ins positive umkehren und diesen
schwung auch mitnehmen der jetzigen
bundesregierung dass wir das bis zum
herbst angehen ich glaube es ist
technisch möglich dass man haupt und
neben diagnosen aus dem krankenhaus
zeitnah aus leiten kann das wenn wir im
herbst und wir werden vor dieser frage
im herbst stehen und im nächsten winter
dass wir die dann auch wirklich zeitnah
beantworten noch ein satz dazu wir
arbeiten bereits das hat ja über viele
jahre die stadt gefahren arbeiten
bereits an einer schnellen ausladung der
haupt- und neben diagnosen
tagesaktuell an einen an eine zentrale
stelle die wir dann also entweder beim
robert-koch-institut oder im
bundesgesundheitsministerium auswachsen
das wird auch sehr schnell passieren
also damit hier nicht der eindruck
entsteht man das wäre und nicht möglich
oder es wurde jahrelang dauern oder die
einführung der elektronischen
patientenakte zur voraussetzung das ist
nicht der fall wir haben jetzt eine
verzögerte meldung und dieser auftrag
wird nicht vorgenommen das habe ich ja
gerade eingeräumt aber das lässt sich in
sehr kurzer zeit ändern weil wir ja
gemeinsam auch mit dem mit der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft aber auch mit
dem in egg dem institut welches also
dafür zuständig ist dass die
fallpauschalen abgerechnet werden können
arbeiten wir bereits an einer lösung so
dass dieses problem was sehr lange
bestand also ich denke dass bestand seit
2003 19 jahre dass wir dieses problem in
der möglicherweise nächste woche oder in
den nächsten wochen zumindest also lösen
im saal geht es weiter bei herrn grimmen
auf der von uns aus gesehen linken seite
herr lauterbach herr villa ich wollte
sie nochmal frage zudem genießen des
staates und der verkürzung er wieder
haben sie die verkürzung eigenmächtig
entschieden ohne den gesundheitsminister
ins bild zu setzen oder wie lief diese
entscheidung ab oder haben sie herrn
lauterbach von mir
vielleicht fange ich an die lage ist ja
auch schon beschrieben worden wir haben
dazu ja zahlreiche anfangen bekomme ich
will ihr sommer ist wichtigste in den
vordergrund stellen also bevor wir hier
präzise also
dabei uns den kopf zerbrechen wer wusste
wann was weil ich gleich auch zudem will
ich nicht ausweichen und ich gleich
etwas zu sagen aber man muss erstmal die
inhaltliche frage in den vordergrund
stellen ist das sinnvoll dass der
genießen den status auf drei monate
verkürzt wird und da ist die schnelle
antwort aus unserer sicht ja denn für
den konservativen kurs den wir hier
fahren müssen sich die leute die genesen
sind darauf verlassen können dass sie
andere nicht ansteckt und weil sie sich
selbst angesteckt haben ich würde sagen
beispiel also darstellen und dass in der
villa unter einer meinung wenn jetzt ich
mich auf den genesenen ver status
verlassen und bin im vierten monat also
infiziert war es sogar möglicherweise
gar nicht
und halte mich dann auf in einer im
umfeld von menschen die ich dann
gefährde und infiziere dann also habe
ich mich auf den genesenen status
verlassen der de facto nicht da waren
das ist bei omikron der fall liegt und
das lager das problem als derjenige der
sich an der delta
variante infekt sie infiziert haben oder
infiziert hatte dass er schon nach drei
monaten sich an omikron infizieren kann
somit der inhaltliche punkt das richtige
für diesen inhaltlichen punkt hatten wir
auf der fachebene austausch da war auch
keinen dissenz zwischen im rk ii und
unserem haus und ich habe da auch keine
also allen wende somit also ist das die
richtige entscheidung und auch um das
zuvor wegzunehmen also für diese
entscheidung setzen wir unser auf
europäischer ebene einwände ist er
bekannt dass auf europäischer ebene auch
immer die sechs monate gelten wir setzen
uns auf der ebene dafür ein als drei
monate sind zum verfahren selbst also
auf der fachebene ist darüber sehr
intensiv gesprochen worden das ist ja
bekannt womit ich also vertraut war war
das also an dem
samstag vor der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dass da der
also
quarantäne und isolations status in der
korona schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung verändert wurde in
diese diskussion war ich auch selbst
sehr eng einbezogen darüber hatten wir
auch viel miteinander gesprochen aber
ich hatte ich war in die frage wann wird
denn der genießen den status so
verändert war ich nicht angezogen das
heißt das wusste ich nicht ich hatte
damit gerechnet dass das später
geschieht wenn es mir bekannt gewesen
wäre hätte ich es natürlich auch also an
dem freitag also in der also im
bundesrat also mitgeteilt ich wusste
nicht dass dies schon sozusagen
beschlusslage war und da hat es eben ein
kommunikationsproblem gegeben aber da
bitte ich auch also um verständnis die
situation ist noch wie folgt dieses
gesetz wo eine
bewertung des robert-koch-instituts
unmittelbar dann quasi also
gesetzgeberische wirkung hat weil das
einfach weiß gesetz ist das haben wir
zum ersten mal eingesetzt dass zum
ersten mal so genutzt worden und dass es
beim ersten mal bei einer unter fr da an
kommunikationsproblem gibt das also
hatte ich für vertretbar wir haben die
kommunikationswege jetzt einvernehmlich
verbessert sodass wir also wenn das
zusammen hat diese veränderung werden ja
noch häufiger jetzt stattfinden so dass
wir uns also vorher gemeinsam gedanken
machen wie wir das kommuniziert von wem
das auch die vorlaufzeiten korrekt sind
denn das damit haben ja die länder recht
dass das mitgeteilt werden muss und auch
die bürger zum schluss war das ist ja
auch ein vorlauf den die bürger
benötigen möchten sie das ergänze ein
händler nein ich habe eigentlich keine
ergänzungen das ist die extraktion
eine frage gibt es online gestellt vom
kollegen themen steffen von zeit online
da geht es auch um den genesenen status
immer noch einen schritt weiter er
bezieht sich auf eine äußerung des
ministers dass eine infektion mit der
omicron variante keine immunisierung
bewirkt so schreibt er ist warum werden
dann in deutschland noch genießen in
zertifikate ausgestellt wenn doch kein
schutz vor weiterer erkrankungen besteht
also dass ich bin ich war es jetzt nicht
so wohl dieser ausfallen soll was die
das ist eine immunisierung also gibt das
ist natürlich klar das problem bei nikon
ist nicht das kann immer visierung gibt
sondern dass die immunisierung nicht
lange anhält das ist ja der punkt also
ich hab ich erwähne dies immer also in
folgender hinsicht war es ein wichtiger
punkt es gibt viele die jetzt also zum
teil noch nicht geimpft sind und denken
welches omikron graf habe dann bin ich
also immunisiert für den herbst aber im
herbst also kommt dann möglicherweise
eine andere welle und das trifft mich
dann nimmt das ist aber nicht so die
studien zeigen dass selbst vor der
del-tabelle oder vor der delta infektion
die omikron also erkrankung nur einen
sehr geringen schutz gibt und zwar
unmittelbare unmittelbaren nach der
infektion und zwar in der größenordnung
von ungefähr 50 prozent das heißt von
dieser immunisierung wirkung omikron
infiziert wird im herbst von dem was wir
derzeit wissenschaftlich ab können
nichts übrig bleiben dass davon wird
nichts übrig bleiben nicht was sie bitte
herrn kann man die handys oder ein
wieder da wirklich zur hilfe zu kommen
nach dem motto im die also die
preiswerteste impfung für den herbst ist
jetzt eine armee von also infektionen
die vielleicht nicht so mit verlaub das
ist aus zweierlei hinsicht falsch zum
anderen ist es nicht gesichert dass das
mild verläuft und cupid kann passieren
alles mögliche und zum zweiten mann hat
dann auch vielleicht mit zitronen
gehandelt oder wahrscheinlich weil im
herbst ist man ja gar nicht geschützt
worden sie das ja also die fachliche
frage ist die ist klar so zu beantworten
es ist natürlich so dass alle diejenigen
die nur genesen sind also die das glück
hatten diese infektion halt dann auch
gut zu überstehen wobei es ja auch viele
leute gibt die chinesen sind die aber
trotzdem noch zum beispiel longo witt
haben also dass diese immunität dem
nicht so belastbar ist wie eine
immunität die durch eine immunisierung
hervorgerufen wird und etwas was man
auch nicht vergessen darf ist die
immunität in abhängigkeit von der
krankheit die man durch gemacht hat
schwankt auch sehr stark also das ist ja
der grund warum eben der genesenen
status eine bestimmte länge noch hat der
schwankt sehr stark nach einer impfung
haben sie eine viel definierte hre
immunität das heißt sie können viel
besser aussagen wie lange diese
immunität enthalten wird also insofern
ist das wissenschaftlich klar was ich
habe das nur ergänzen möchte das kann
man 100 prozent unterstreichen ich
glaube wir sollten uns diesem problem
vielleicht einmal detailliert widmen in
diesem jahr das würde viel geld kosten
das ist ganz klar
aber ich glaube wir brauchen ein
verlängern schnitts untersuchungen zu
diesen fragestellungen so ähnlich wie
das in
england haben so was in deutschland auch
wir haben diese untersuchungen zum teil
schon aber ich glaube wir müssen noch
einmal richtig geld in die hand nehmen
und breite teile der bevölkerung auch
wirklich testen gucken wie viele
antikörper haben sie heute wie viele
haben sie nach der erkrankung wie sieht
der status im sommer außen wie sieht er
im nächsten herbst auch wenn es wirklich
teuer ist ich glaube das wird uns so
wichtige informationen im nächsten
herbst bringt
in sei geht es weiter mit der nächsten
frage von frau wolfs kämpft
damit auch nochmal zum genesenen status
ist ja nicht nur so dass in europa die
sechs monate gelten sondern dass diese
bewertung des lka auf die bundesregelung
durchgreifen aber die länder
verordnungen zum teil bereits in sechs
monaten bleiben das heißt in der bahn
und am arbeitsplatz bin ich drei monate
chinesen im restaurant oder bei einer
veranstaltung sechs monate ist das denn
wie erklären sie dass er lauterbach das
ist auch so nicht sinnvoll
wir werden natürlich mit den ländern
also über die umsetzung sprechen das ist
gar keine frage
und das ist halt so dass wir hat hier
also vorgaben machen können die auch
eigentlich verbindlich sind aber wenn
die länder dann also davon abweichen
können da schlecht könnte das schlecht
kontrollieren ich habe das für falsch
inhaltlich spreche einfach inhaltlich da
macht es also aus meiner sicht also
keinen sinn diese differenzierung
vorzunehmen aber wir sind mit den
ländern im kontakt reden darüber und ich
hoffe dass relatio einvernehmlichen und
gemeinsamen lösungen kommen
man überzeugt hier am besten also auf
der inhalt schiene dass man einfach
erläutert das was wir hier also
beschließen was wir vorgeben das muss
auch stichhaltig sein und das problem
ist eben dass also der genesenen status
also nicht für sechs monate her hält in
dem sinne dass ich dann sicher sein kann
dass ich mich nicht infizieren und wenn
ich infiziert bin andere nicht auch
infiziert somit also ist es inhaltlich
wichtig sei aber das ist noch
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
in ihren und jetzt langsam der stadt ich
würde wenn sie alle zeit haben noch fünf
bis zehn minuten drauf schlagen weil
noch so viele fragen offen sind eine
frage online gestellt von gernot heller
an den minister der bitte darum nochmal
zu erläutern warum man nicht auf einer
micro unangepassten impfstoff warten
sollte beim boostern denn der dürfte
doch wirksamer schützen sehr wichtige
frage also eben die die studie es gibt
ja zwei große studien die derzeit
gemacht werden also mit biotech und mit
moderner wo es also um angepasste
impfstoffe geht werden diese impfstoffe
dann da sind dann werden diese
impfstoffe also in großer menge
produziert und werden dann weltweit
ausgeliefert
realistischerweise wäre somit ein großes
volumen dieser impfstoffe erst also ja
im mai wahrscheinlich zu erwarten und
ich appelliere einfach an alle sich
jetzt postern zu lassen denn also ich
sags mal etwas zugespitzt zu also wir
haben die omikron wäre jetzt daher
brauche ich auch jetzt die booster
impfung die mich schützt und das kann
dann nur der impfstoff stander da da da
ist wir wissen auch hat es eben schon
also erläutert das vor beispielsweise
tod durch pid die booster impfung mit
den vorhandenen also impfstoffen also
das risiko im vergleich zum umkämpften
um 99 prozent sinkt wann haben wir das
in der impfstoffforschung jemals
beobachtet das ist fantastisch
somit gibt es medizinisch keinen grund
zu warten und es gibt
epidemiologisch sogar einen grund nicht
zu warten weil zwar zugespitzt aus was
der omicron dem stoff kommt aber er ist
nicht mehr wert wenn er kommt zu einem
zeitpunkt wo die mikrowelle zu ende ist
herr karadzic
ich will dazu vielleicht noch mal
ergänzen weil wir jetzt auch aktuelle
daten wieder bekommen haben zum beispiel
diese woche aus frankreich da waren 1
prozent der intensivpatienten gepostete
patienten an das zeigt schon wie extrem
wirksam das ganze ist und was wir in der
öffentlichkeit vielleicht auch immer ein
bisschen vergessen ist wir haben nicht
nur die b-zellen diese antikörper bilden
sollen werden auch t zellen und diese
antwort ist relativ robust und schützt
einfach vor dem schweren verlauf
deswegen ist es wirklich eminent wichtig
und ich selbst bin gewusst hat mit dem
impfstoff den es gab und würde jetzt
auch nicht auf die idee kommen irgendwie
noch eine vierte dosis zu nehmen sondern
man kann wirklich ganz in ruhe warten
was passiert und die jetzige bewusst
wirklich das absolut entscheidende frage
sei jetzt weiter bei frau ist
herr lauterbach ich würde gerne nochmal
zum genesenen status zurück und würde
sie fragen werden sie nicht einbezogen
waren das wird ja zu der frage ob herr
wieder eigenmächtig gehandelt hat und
wenn er wieder eigenmächtig gehandelt
hat ob er noch tragbar ist und ja wieder
sie haben jetzt zwei wochen lang dazu
nichts gesagt und auch heute dazu
schmale wie ich hatte lauterbach in
verboten dazu stellung zu nehmen als
dienstherr unter lauterbach wie ist das
dann am kabinettstisch wie sagen sie
setzen sich für drei monate ein das
außenministerium für sechs monate was
kommt dabei raus 4,5 oder was ist das
dann im gesamten viele
namen habe gesagt ja wie la nicht
eigenmächtig gehandelt weil es hat ja es
gab ja diese intensive
zusammenarbeit auf der fachebene
das ist ja sie fachebene hat ja lange
darüber gesprochen hat sich das gut
überlegt die diskussion die ich jetzt
hier nur oberflächlich reproduziere hat
auf der fachebene stattgefunden das
einzige war ein kommunikationsproblem
und als kommunikationsproblem lag darin
dass ich auf also dass ich noch nicht
informiert war dass das bereits an dem
tag also in kraft treten sollte das
alles was dazu zu sagen ist und ich
finde es schade dass wir uns also mit
dem kommunikationsproblem jetzt soviel
auseinandersetzen ich bin für jede frage
dankbar wo es um die inhalte da war ja
also jetzt von etwas vorgetragen also
wie ist das also mit dem
außenministerium das ministerium
verwaltungsrat das außenministerium ist
ja natürlich zuständig für alles was
sagen diese genesenen also werte angeht
für die reise verordnung na das ist ja
das was das außenministerium hier also
auch mit unserer hilfe im übrigen
entscheiden muss wir hingegen sind dafür
zuständig was ist der nationale
genesenen status müssen natürlich für
uns entscheidend für unser land aber wir
wirken natürlich auf andere länder
einzieht mit zählt jetzt mit macht es so
wie wir bringen die daten und das ist ja
auch zu gewesen und von daher ist es
also
das erkennen also
wäre es ja kein widerspruch geben und
für die reise verordnung also gilt es
dann nach wie vor also wenn man jetzt
aus deutschland reist in ein land wo die
sechs monate gelten dann gelten doch die
sechs monate kommt man aus dem ausland
nach deutschland ist man der nationalen
regelung also
ausgesetzt und dann gelten
warum haben sie nach dem sturm der
entrüstung und den vielen problemen die
das ja auch einfach organisatorische und
inhaltliche für millionen von menschen
bedeutet nicht nochmal eine
übergangsregelung eingeführt von sechs
oder acht wochen die das problem
zumindest kritisch reagiert hätte
zunächst muss ich mal darauf hinweisen
dass ich in der bevölkerung also jetzt
in breiten teilen der bevölkerung diesen
sturm der entrüstung überhaupt nicht
wahrgenommen habe denn diejenigen also
die chinesen sind die sind sehr häufig
auch bereits geimpft und sind dann von
ganz anderen regeln betroffen das ist ja
nur die kleine gruppe derer die chinesen
sind und die sonst noch nie vorher
genießen sind und auch nie games worden
sind und jetzt lassen sie uns gemeinsam
mal darüber nachdenken
also wie groß dieser gruppe sind das ist
ja die gruppe derjenigen die also die
impfung ablehnen noch nie gelesen noch
nie gelesen ist und die impfung ablehnt
die kleine gruppe und mit dieser gruppe
habe ich in der tat jeden tag probleme
aber etliche probleme
orientiere sich nicht an der dauer des
chinesen status sondern das sind zum
teil leute die sagen kubik gibt es gar
nicht oder also die impfung schadet mehr
als dass die nutzungszeit uns verbringen
sie in erinnerung also dass die
allermeisten die genesene sind
mittlerweile entweder schon mal genießen
sind oder auch schon geimpft sind und
dann spielt dass er gar keine rolle
eine frage online kommt von jürgen
klöckner vom handelsblatt er fragt nach
welchen kriterien und in welchen stufen
sollten lockerungen der maßnahme folgen
wir haben in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz entschieden
dass wir lockerungen in aussicht stellen
werden die welle ausgebrochen ist und
ich glaube dass das tatsächlich also ein
auch eine sehr realistische perspektive
ich hatte eben schon darauf hingewiesen
wir sind eigentlich auf einem pfad
unterwegs der recht gut vorhersehbar ist
also bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wegen
wir uns ungefähr genau da wo wir bei der
modellierung der arbeit die wir machen
wollten also erwartet hatten liegen
sogar ein bisschen besser das modell des
robert-koch-instituts haben wir ja quasi
gefüttert mit maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen wollen haben dann modelliert
was sollen diese maßnahmen bringen und
es läuft ungefähr so wie wir es uns
vorgestellt haben das bedeutet aber auch
dass wir damit rechnen können dass
vielleicht mitte februar vielleicht
jetzt durch ba2 etwas verspätet da
könnte sich dass die lange noch ein
bisschen verändern dann könnte sagen
dass es ende februar wird aber dann
gehen die fahrer zahlen runter und wir
hoffen dass die fallzahlen dann runter
gehen ohne dass die älteren
bevölkerungsgruppen jemals
überproportional stark betroffen gewesen
sind das ist das ist der plan in dem
sinne muss ja offen sein also was ist
der plan was macht die bundesregierung
eigentlich hier haben die einen das ist
der plan wir wollen sozusagen über diese
geile wegkommen baa2 wird das ein
bisschen der schweren das wird nach
hinten raus das vielleicht noch ein
bisschen vergessen aber wir wollen eine
weitere mikrowelle also verhindern das
wäre zum beispiel der fall wenn wir
jetzt zu stark die also kontakte
reduziert hätten dann wäre bei einer
späteren öffnung während die fahrbahn
wieder hoch gegangen das wollten wir
nicht wir wollten nur eine welle das ist
so gemacht dass die eine welle also
sagen wir ihren zenit im mittelalter
februar etwas später vielleicht haben
soll und dass ihr zu jedem zeitpunkt
durch die maßnahmen die darauf
ausgerichtet sind die eltern gut
schützen wenn wir das machen kann man
danach lockern das ist also mit haben
wir eine lockerung perspektive ich sage
mal für die zweite hälfte februar wenn
die fahrzeugen herunter geben oder
vielleicht anfangen mehr als das hängt
aber ein bisschen davon ab wie es jetzt
geht aber bisher sind wir einigermaßen
gut auf dem weg unterwegs den wir uns
vorgenommen hatten
würde ich jetzt noch eine frage online
stellen und herrn papas hier sei die
letzte frage war das nicht doch dann
müssen wir es wirklich beenden dort
wenigstens hat die hauptstadtstudio
fragt auch sie herr minister sie haben
immer wieder aufnommen kopitar risiken
hingewiesen und gewarnt wollten deswegen
die gesamtzahlen möglichst gering halten
gilt das jetzt unter omikron nicht mehr
geht es jetzt wirklich in
anführungsstrichen nur noch darum ältere
zu schützen fragt simon koppers
weiterhin ein problem wie wir wissen
dass also long coffee
weniger schwer verläuft für diejenigen
die sich infizieren aber vorher geimpft
waren das wussten wir sehr lange zeit
nicht das war also kein
klares ergebnis gewesen aber wissen
jetzt also dass diejenigen die erkranken
und geimpft sind also ein deutlich
reduziertes longo fit risiko haben und
somit ist es so dass wir bei den
jüngeren weiter in long cockpit probleme
haben aber wir haben natürlich einen
großen teil von gm ssten mittlerweile
das hilft hier auf der strecke wenn es
so gewesen wäre erst bei der omicron
variante diejenigen die in sich
infizieren games oder ungeimpfte sind 40
sicher auch viele geimpfte genauso stark
bedroht gewesen wären deutschland kommt
dann wäre das thema sehr viel präsenter
gewesen somit das ist ein wichtiges
problem aber es hat sich etwas
relativiert gottseidank durch die hohe
impfquoten und die jetzt bekannte
tatsache dass wissen wir noch gar nicht
so lange dass infizierte geimpfte
weniger häufig und weniger schwere
anleihe käufe den kranken
dann herr papas mit der letzten frage
für
frage
was kann sie auch ein bisschen näher ans
mikro gehen dann hatte sie bronze drin
das betrifft diejenigen die den
impfstoff johnson johnson bekommen haben
es ist ja im vergangenen sommer das mit
diesem impfstoff nur eine durch braucht
statt
jetzt werden die gäste mit johnson
johnson als gangster mit einer dosis
erhalten und wenn sie jetzt impfen
lassen sind sie nur zweimal geimpft und
nicht gebucht das geht auch aus
währungen
lebt
gemacht
wir haben diesbezüglich gar nichts
falsch gemacht sondern das nennt sich
die wissenschaft schaltet fort so geht
es immer weiter wir lernen dazu die
wissenschaft startet ford wir also haben
der erkenntnisstand aus der impfstoff
damals eingesetzt wurde war der dass
eine impfung wie zwei impfungen also mit
anderen impfstoffen wirklich habe in dem
song selbst als ebenfalls sehr viel
eingesetzt
beispielsweise bei polizisten aber auch
also bei menschen
die barrieren überwinden müssen um sich
impfen zu lassen die man dann also nur
einmal sieht daher ist er immer noch da
gerne eingesetzt worden das habe auch
ich getan aber dann kam hat die neue
studien lage und die studienlage zeigt
dass es nicht haltbar wenn das nicht
hart weiß dann müssen wir halt der
wissenschaft folgend müssen wir dann wie
ich eben auch schon sagen sagte der
wahrheit folgend müssen wir dann die
regeln wir können jetzt nicht hingehen
und sagen
na ja eigentlich wirkt der impfstoff
nicht so stark aus dass wir sagen können
jemand der damit gäben zwar und noch
eine anregung der gilt als geburtstag
eigentlich wirklich nicht so stark aber
wir bleiben trotzdem dabei war das
politisch bequemer ist so kann man nicht
arbeiten und so bin ich ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht gewählt zu arbeiten somit ist
es so
der impfstoff ist halt nicht so stark
wie damals
bewertet wurde in der literatur
es sind einige ganz wenige fragen
unbeantwortet geblieben ich bitte um
verständnis dass wir trotzdem jetzt
schluss machen müssen um hier zu lüften
und umzubauen für die regierungspartei
im anschluss kommt ich danke unseren
gästen fürs kommen und das beantworten
der fragen